Recyclerview was added to
the support library to
ultimately perform many of the same
functions that list view does.
The addition of material
design list item animations
necessitated a significant change
in the way adapters worked.
The list view code was already
exceptionally complicated.
A relatively monolithic code
base handled Layout, Recycling,
Selection, UI decorations like dividers,
Scrolling, Empty View.
The decision was made to start over and
produce a more flexible control.
RecyclerView is focused on doing
precisely what its name suggests.
Managing the recycling of views.
Most of the functions of ListView have
been separated int separate RecyclerView
components.
And we've added an additional
animator component.
One of the exciting ways this is
being used is with LayoutMangers.
Which allows us to create different
pluggable layout experiences.
Of course, we have standard vertical
list views, and horizontal lists.
It's a big deal if you've been
doing Android for a while.
It wasn't actually easy
to do a horizontal list.
Grid layouts and this very cool
staggered grid layout manager which
lays out children of different sizes.
Which supports horizontal and
vertical layouts as well as the ability
to layout children in reverse.
One of the key features that
Recyclerview supports is
custom animations.
So if we delete an item
the default animator will
nicely animate the closing
of the space left behind.
And because the animator,
like everything else in
Recyclerview is plugable.
We can change it and
customize it, the way it works.
And, because the animator, like just
about everything else in Recycler View,
is pluggable, we can customize
the way this works in the future.